drama red oh oh the gun guy
yeah yeah he really took a shot
yeah what was his thing he brought a gun
to a club on Instagram
twice wow well you know if you find the
police you gotta protect yourself
brought a gun to a club twice and then
talked about it on Instagram he wants in
the car oh really
I don't know this guy sounds fun
why can't
[Music]
I can't even
he's actually Irish
what does that mean sir
all right he got he got the board
can't people have guns he's flashing on
Instagram live oh is that bad
so if you're in the NBA you can't own a
gun
it's confusing right I'm sure there's
other NBA players with a gun right the
gun's kind of like an n-word you know
you can say they just can't do it on the
internet